[Music]
2018's superhero body count was
impressive to say the least
but 2019's promises to stack at least as
high
mostly thanks to the many landmark
movies shows and comic story lines that
have been released over the course of
the year
obviously there are spoilers ahead and
before you ask about the mcu's black
widow and iron man
just remember that earlier this year we
covered superheroes who sadly died in
the first half of 2019
so if you want to see them make sure you
check out our previous video
after the whole thanos thing that's been
going down in the mcu these last couple
of years
marvel might be forgiven for thinking
they had the edge on killing off
characters by scrubbing them from
existence
but cw's the flash begs to differ since
that's how the speedster xs also known
as nora west allen was killed off in the
show's season 5 finale
during this episode xs gets erased from
reality when team flash's defeat
of the villain cicada changes nora's
future timeline
in an earlier episode the show's heroes
learn nora has been running to
and from the future getting tips on how
to beat cicada from the imprisoned
villain reverse flash but in the finale
the team figures out reverse flash's
motivation
in the future cicada's dagger keeps
reverse flash powerless
so he wants flash to destroy it
regardless of this discovery
the team is forced to destroy cicada's
dagger
hoping to tie up loose ends they then
travel to the future to stop
reverse flash the heroes seem to be
winning the fight
but nora begins suffering the effects of
the timeline change
reverse flash tells the heroes the only
way to save nora is for her to enter his
negative speed force
but she refuses not wanting to suffer
from the negative emotions necessary to
access it
reverse flash escapes and nora dies
embracing her mother and father
you'd be on shaky ground calling raven's
comic book counterpart
the marvel version not the teen titan a
superhero since
she tends to just veer between moral
ambiguity and
outright villainy but ever since 2011's
x-men first class
the movie franchises raven also known as
mystique has been one of the good guys
and she pays dearly for her heroics in
2019's dark phoenix
shortly after jean grey leaves the
mansion it becomes clear that professor
x not only
psychically blocked jean's traumatic
childhood memories
but lied to her about the fate of her
father because of this
charles knows where to look for jean
after she leaves
her father's home once they find her the
x-men are no match for the emerging
phoenix
she easily fights them off even injuring
quicksilver so badly he's benched for
the rest of the film
when raven tries to talk gene down an
out of control
gene flings raven back through the air
the blue skinned mutant is impaled on a
piece of wreckage
raven's death brings with it
catastrophic consequences
magneto emerges to seek revenge on
phoenix
beast leaves the x-men to help magneto
and the x-men and magneto's followers
find themselves on an all-too-familiar
collision course
better known as the hellfire club's
black queen
the comic book version of celine gallio
doesn't even enjoy the occasional act of
moral ambiguity
mystique does she's 100 bad guy
but just like her actual abilities the
morality of dark phoenix's celine is
vastly different from the comic version
the film first depicts celine as one of
the inhabitants of the island genocide
where magneto oversees a growing
community of mutant refugees
along with beast eneriki magneto brings
celine with him to new york city to kill
phoenix
and she spends most of that fight using
her own telepathic abilities to keep
professor x's powers busy
after the mutants are captured by a
government strike force and loaded onto
a train
celine joins the x-men against a horde
of invading aliens
unfortunately celine doesn't survive the
battle during a lull in the fight
against the aliens
well this happens
and sure her body is never actually
shown but since this version of the
character
isn't nearly as powerful as her comic
counterpart her fate is nonetheless
clear enough
as far as anyone knows melissa benoist
will continue playing supergirl well
into the future
but season four of supergirl saw one of
her characters killed off nonetheless
this season had been noiced doing double
duty as both supergirl and a clone
raised in the fictional eastern european
nation
of casnia the clone was initially
referred to as
snowbird and later nicknamed red
daughter referring to the classic dc
elseworlds miniseries
superman red sun which had kal-el raised
in the soviet union
rather than kansas lex luthor allies
himself with the kasnians and uses the
opportunity to manipulate red daughter
and win her loyalty
unfortunately in supergirl's season 4
finale
red daughter learns lex's loyalty only
goes one way
lex fools the kasnians into believing
he's supporting an invasion of the
united states
when in fact he uses the opportunity to
destroy the invading khasneyans and
falsely prove himself as a hero to the
us
when supergirl confronts luthor with
what he's done she finds herself needing
red daughter's help
the clone eventually dies coming between
lex and supergirl
after lex tries to blast the show's hero
with kryptonite energy
the kryptonite kills red daughter but as
she dies
she releases a wave of energy which
supergirl uses to grow strong enough to
finally defeat luthor
the second episode of amazon primes the
boys sees the series claim its first
superhero victim
but it's far from the last translucent
is captured by the boys after he follows
hughie from the sevens headquarters
and attacks him at his electronic store
shop huey and billy butcher managed to
incapacitate translucent but can't kill
him because of his super dense skin
butcher then brings the unconscious hero
to his old colleague frenchie
who eventually has the idea to insert a
bomb
into the incapacitated hero with huey
still new to life as an outlaw
the notion of gruesomely killing
translucent doesn't sit well with him
and sure enough towards the end of the
second episode he waits until he's alone
with the hero
and proceeds to free him from his cage
but before translucent can escape
huey changes his mind and sets off the
bomb inside the soup
blowing him to smithereens the comic
book the boys is based on tends to be
much bloodier than the show
though in this case the series handled
huey's christening into butcher's world
in a much darker fashion
like the show huey is the first member
of the boys to kill a soup in the comic
he kills the young blarney from the team
teenage kicks
but blarney's death at huey's hands in
the comic is an accident
while the huey of the show knows exactly
what he's doing when he kills
translucent
the accidental death of huey's
girlfriend robin by the speedster hero a
train is what sends huey on his quest
for justice
before his death translucent reveals
that a train was with his girlfriend
popclaw before he killed robin the boys
would likely have never discovered this
on their own
as atran has been keeping his
relationship with popclaw a secret
because she's seen
as being something of a c lister in the
superhero community
this news makes popclaw a perfect target
for the boys
posing as workmen they plant
surveillance devices in her apartment
and when popclaw accidentally kills her
landlord the boys are there to blackmail
her into giving them information
when a train later finds out that word
has got out about the drug
compound v he forces popclaw to go into
hiding
worried that homelander might find out
about it at the same time
a train correctly suspects popclaw might
be the boy's source for their
information
when she finally admits what happened
with her landlord and the boys
a train uses his super speed to grab two
syringes of heroin and injects them into
popclaw before she can stop him
she then dies from the ensuing overdose
the most brutal death in the first
season of the boys is surely that
of messmer a mind-reading former teen
hero who has since fallen into obscurity
and been relegated to the convention
circuit
so what am i thinking of
[Music]
i'm thinking the same thing cool
in episode six frenchie and mother's
milk track down mesmer at a convention
and convince him to help them in return
mother's milk promises to reunite mesmer
with the daughter he hasn't seen in
years
butcher isn't happy when he finds out
frenchie and mother's milk have gone to
a soup for help
however and unfortunately his fears come
true by the end of the sixth episode
mesmer has given homelander information
on every last one of the boys
in the hopes it will win him favor with
the seven and bring him back
into the inner circle of successful
superheroes homelander takes messmer's
phone
which contains photographs of the boys
and flies off
of course messmer's reward never
materializes
at least not the one he was hoping for
butcher catches the psychic as he tries
to flee the city and beats him to death
in a public restroom
but not before he tells messmer to use
his powers on him
so the soup can see exactly what
butcher's planning to do to him
if you've been following titan's second
season then you know something has been
brewing with the team regarding a past
conflict with a mercenary deathstroke
in the second season's fourth episode
things finally kick off after
garth also known as aqualad is killed
off
aqualad spends most of the episode
trying to woo
donna troy and it's clear he's had a
thing for her for years
they finally sleep together towards the
end of the episode but it's only
hours before donna troy plans to
secretly leave titan's tower for
themyscira once dick grayson tells
aqualad what donna's planning
aqualad finds donna at the airport to
profess his
love and he hopes stop her from leaving
he catches donna and her older mentor
jillian before they get on the plane
and things look hopeful for their young
love before deathstroke
fires on them from a hidden position
garth turns and protects
donna from the bullet taking it in the
chest and dying
donna and jillian managed to escape and
by the end of the episode
donna and the rest of the titans are
ready to exact their vengeance
this wide line marvel comic story war of
the realms was one of marvel's biggest
events in 2019
and in war of the realms number two
asgard loses one of its favorite
daughters
valkyrie fighting atop a pile of slain
trolls and dark elves
valkyrie reaches out to malekith
architect of the war of the realms
to stop hiding and face her malekith
surprises her and stabs her from behind
and the issue ends with the dark elf
mercilessly beheading her
while this seems as a conclusive end to
a character you'll find in
any marvel comic malakath doesn't rid
the world of valkyrie
though he does kill off broom hilda
three weeks before the release of war of
the realms number two
marvel's editor-in-chief cb cebulsky
announced at chicago's c2e2 convention
that a new valkyrie comic would spin out
of war of the realms
the day after issue 2's release news
broke that it would not be broomhilda's
spirit that would pass the mantle of
valkyrie to jane foster
foster is played by natalie portman in
the mcu films
and in the comics took over the mantle
of thor for four years
until being forced to sacrifice mjolnir
to stop the monstrous man-gog
in 2018's mighty thor number 705.
last year the mcu's heimdall died at
thanos hands in the opening sequence of
avengers infinity war
in valkyrie jane foster number two
heimdall's comic book counterpart dies
as well
though the villain who kills him isn't
quite as powerful as thanos
war of the realms had come to an end by
this point but the shock waves are still
being felt across the universe
jane foster replaced the late broom
hilda as valkyrie at the end of the
event
launching her new solo series valkyrie
jane foster
in the first issue foster defeats some
minor villains who stole the original
valkyrie sword after her death
but one of them gets away the sword
dragonfang
is claimed by the psychotic daredevil
villain bullseye
as the issue ends bullseye runs heimdall
through with dragonfang from behind
heimdall initially survives and helps
foster battle the villain
but later dies from his wounds after
successfully destroying dragonfang
as he dies he begs foster not to take
him to valhalla
but to bring him beyond the 10 realms so
he can see what is there
foster agrees promising to embark on a
journey into mystery with the late
bridge keeper
echoing the title of the comic in which
marvel's thor first appeared in 1962.
tony stark iron man number 15 sees the
return of an old friend to the marvel
universe
an artificial intelligence version of
tony stark
oh it's good to be back the stark ai
became active after the events of civil
war ii
left tony in a coma and acted as a
mentor to riri williams
also known as ironheart and occupied one
of tony's suits to help his friends
against hydra
in the marvel wide secret empire event
the real stark now out of his coma
testifies in front of congress in tony
stark iron man number 15
and one of the senators has somehow
gotten his hands on the stark ai
he reactivates it in the middle of the
proceedings and when iron man
is attacked by a bizarre android
comprised of the fused bodies of vision
and wonderman
the ai is there to help him
unfortunately
tony knows the only thing that will stop
the android
is an emp cascade which will also kill
off the ai
the stark ai tells him to go through
with it anyway sacrificing itself in the
process
but that's not all since the beginning
of tony stark iron man
tony and his colleagues have been
dealing with the notion of whether or
not
artificial intelligence deserve the same
rights as humans
while stark is testifying there are
ai-driven robots protesting in the
street
and his emp cascade kills all of them as
well
with the deaths of kid loki and valkyrie
the asgardians of the galaxy arguably
suffer
more than any other superhero team in
marvel's
war of the realms event asgardians of
the galaxy number 10 the series finale
takes one more victim from the
asgardian's ranks
as scourge the executioner makes a last
stand that is brimming with dark irony
scourge was freshly resurrected when he
joined the asgardians of the galaxy
as his previous death was one of the
most memorable in marvel comics history
he died in the 1985 classic thor number
362
fighting off waves of undead soldiers to
give his asgardian brethren
time to escape hell
for asgard
this time around however scourge's foes
are much
different the angels of heaven
inexplicably side with the dark elf
malekith in war of the realms and
scourge ends up joining fellow asgardian
angela in heaven itself once there
scourge holds off the angels to give
angela the time to summon an
army of undead asgardian warriors
ironically
having died his first death against an
army of the dead
scourge dies his second death helping to
summon another army of the dead to his
side
after he succumbs to his wounds and the
battle is won scourge awakes in valhalla
the realm of the honored death
valhalla's other residents greet him
warmly
and when he insists he hasn't earned a
place among them they
tell him they all thought the same thing
when they got there
dark beast is a version of hank mccoy
from an alternate reality based on the
1995 age of apocalypse event
and to be fair he wasn't much of a
superhero nevertheless he's been working
with the x-men since cyclops returned
from the dead and started putting a new
team together in
uncanny x-men number 11. in uncanny
x-men number 20
dark beast inadvertently turns on his
benefactors thinking he's helping them
but pays for his mistake with his life
all around the globe
parents are giving their children a new
vaccine designed to suppress
any emerging mutant genes dark beast
tells his teammates he's figured out a
way to counteract the vaccine
he just needs his own agent dispersed in
the upper atmosphere
unfortunately the x-men trust dark beast
and banshee
disperses the agent is ordered the x-men
soon learn what dark beast has failed to
tell them
that once his agent has been dispersed
it wouldn't simply stop the anti-mutant
vaccine from working
if a child receiving the vaccine is a
mutant it will likely kill
them dark beast sees this as an
inestimable success
saying that now human parents won't dare
get their children vaccinated
ignoring cyclops protest the vengeful
mutant magic
uses her powers to teleport dark beast's
head
into the ceiling ending his dark
experiments for good
the current volume of guardians of the
galaxy spun out of the line-wide event
in infinity wars in which gamora
kills her adoptive father thanos in
guardians of the galaxy number one it is
revealed that thanos had arranged to
have his consciousness
uploaded into someone else's body in
case of his untimely death
star fox then assembles a team of dark
guardians
to find and kill the most likely
candidates starting with gamora
while peter quill's guardians try to
save her unfortunately for star fox and
his dark guardians
it turns out gamora isn't the new host
for thanos after all
in guardians of the galaxy number five
it's revealed that it was star fox into
whom thanos's consciousness was uploaded
and it was the asgardian goddess of
death hella who did the deed
after the dark guardians captured gamora
hella appears and
easily brushes them aside she reveals
the truth to star fox and thanos's
consciousness emerges and gains
dominance over his brother's body hella
then brings star fox to nowhere where
thanos's reassembled body awaits
the guardians arrive on nowhere and
gamora runs star fox through
ending his life and stopping a mad
titan's resurrection
the long-awaited cw crossover crisis on
infinite earths finally arrived as 2019
approached its den
and the event's first chapter wasted no
time in taking a major victim
oliver queen aka green arrow he
sacrifices himself in the first episode
to save the population of the besieged
earth 38 home of the arrow vs supergirl
as anti-matter waves threaten to destroy
all the universes in the multiverse
heroes from most of the cw's superhero
series are summoned by the monitor to
save earth 38
and evacuate over 3 billion of its
people to earth 1.
as the heroes fight off the
anti-monitor's armies the monitor
determines earth 38 is lost and
transports the heroes away
green arrow however refuses to leave the
monitor finally brings oliver back to
earth 1.
i calculate 1 billion souls survive due
to his noble sacrifice
oliver dies shortly afterward but he
does get resurrected
sort of in part 3. he's brought back
without a soul
after a group of heroes goes to
purgatory to save him
jim corrigan the spectre in the comics
tells him that he's needed elsewhere to
fulfill his destiny
by part three of crisis on infinite
earths
all the heroes of the multiverse are
dead the only survivors are supergirl
batwoman ryan choi lex luthor
flash jon jones and sarah lance
titans hawk and robin of earth9 the
1960s batman series
earth 66 robin and birds of praise
earth 203 huntress and everyone from
their respective worlds
are all annihilated by the anti-matter
wave
batwoman kills the earth 99 batman and
lex luthor kills and replaces the earth
96
superman earth 90 flash sacrifices
himself to save
earth 1 which unfortunately proves
futile
after the harbinger kills the monitor
the long list of other dead heroes
include
everyone on earth 2 earth 89 batman and
any members of his bat family
the rey and freedom fighters of earth x
the mick rory of earth 74
the heroes of earth 38 the former
superman and other heroes of earth 167
black lightning thunder lightning pariah
and jonah hex
those aren't all the superheroes who
lost their lives in 2019
here are a few other heroes who fell
this year
scout waxman gibbon
joseph starboy vanisher
fellowside alejandra jones
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one